and we actually that kept you should've
been there is the official entry on the
on the official website depicting the
characters backstories above is
indicated they would have been far too
young to be appearing in that particular
story so another one of those topics
where I don't know just seeing enough
things that I'm like okay I just need to
address why I don't address something so
plot holes I generally don't talk about
them and I'm not gonna start I think
this kind of gotten bubbling in my head
after my review for fantastic beast the
crimes of Brenda Wald came out because
there were not a ton but enough comments
where people were like man and you you
didn't even mention how this doesn't
match that and this contradicts that and
how did this even happen and you know
pointing out all these logical fallacies
and plot holes in the thing and putting
that out as if that made my review
somehow less valid because I didn't
bring them up the thing is though at the
end of the day I don't care because
first of all there is no such thing as a
bulletproof script it doesn't exist
a bulletproof script would be boring as
heck because you would have to cover so
much stuff to avoid any possible plot
hole a good film is a film that you
either don't notice the hole so while
you're watching it or if you do you
don't care I think a classic example of
this is the original Jurassic Park Soho
it's the whole iconic thing here because
in the storm and the t-rex busts out
that whole thing
what's going on with the ground in the
t-rex panicked because the the fence
comes down and the t-rex strolls over
and then later a Jeep is getting pushed
through the hole in the fence and on the
other side is a sheer drop did the t-rex
levitate to get there did the ground
suddenly open up out of nowhere like
what is going on there's no way there
would have been that kind of drop-off
just for safety reasons if nothing else
how did that get there
nobody asked nobody cared I mean people
might have spotted after the fact but
you know what I sure as heck didn't
notice I didn't know anyone else who did
until basically things like IMDB came
out and people were browsing you know
Trivium and goof sections and that
wasn't a mistake Steven Spielberg was
fully aware that this made no sense but
he also knew that he's a good enough
filmmaker that he could get people so
invested in the tension of what was
going on no one would notice and he was
right so that's why I don't care about
plot holes because good craft makes plot
holes irrelevant the only time I ever
care about a plot hole is if it is so
glaring that it takes me out of the
movie while I'm watching it if I think
of something
after a movies done like and a few days
later or on a second watch I'm like wait
a minute that's not a big problem for me
that's why I don't do well on plot holes
and the other thing is I feel like plot
holes have become one of the worst
elements of particularly online
criticism like I I'll just say it I
really hate cinemasins
and what I hate about plot hole pointing
out is not that I think it's inherently
wrong to point out these things I think
honestly there's potentially value to be
learned in you know seeing where there
are issues in holes and seeing how good
films work around them or
cover them up and how bad films failed
to do that but that's not how anyone
really presents plotholes they present
them as this snarky we're so much
smarter than the filmmakers we thought
if they think of this and like I don't I
have no interest and trying to prove
myself smarter than a writer or director
I am interested in was I engaged by this
story
was I wrapped up in these characters did
I care do the steaks matter to me not
when we admitted have you ditched when
did that character find out this
information that they just I don't care
I don't I again I only care about a plot
hole when it is so big and so glaring
that it Yanks me out of the story on a
first watch otherwise as far as I'm
concerned it's not a plot hole as to my
definition my definition of a plot hole
is something that breaks the movie while
you're watching it not something that
you have to sit down with a chart to
catalogue in order to get all the things
on and if a plot if these sorts of plot
holes that I'm talking about if they do
actually take you out of the movie if
smaller misses take you out of the movie
whereas I gloss over them cool then that
is an emergent breaking plot hole for
you and your standard for what pulls you
on a movie is probably different than
mine is but the simple existence of
things that don't 100% line up and make
total sense from start to finish is not
an evidence of a movie being bad or
flawed or of whoever found it being
smart it's a reality of storytelling you
make leaps and you do it for the sake of
a good story because that sequence in
Jurassic Park is awesome it's great
storytelling it's amazing tension it's
so good if we cared about plot holes
more than we carry that he cared about
story feel and engagement and
your cane meant we wouldn't have that
scene so I'm not gonna go so far to say
potholes don't matter like at all or
that you know we should forgive massive
glaring plot holes again you'll make
your own call about how big a plot hole
needs to be that it pulls you out of
something but for me if everything else
is working plot holes don't matter and
if the rest of it isn't working
the lack of plot holes wouldn't suddenly
make it a better movie plot holes are
just a reality of storytelling they just
are and a good storyteller knows how to
cover them up work around them get you
to not notice or not care that is true
storytelling craft not making an
airtight story because an airtight plot
hole free story would be so over
detailed and so just nitpicky and in in
terms of and not in so unconcerned with
its flow that it would not be
entertaining and that's why I don't talk
about potholes when I do my reviews of
stuff and I'm not gonna start talking
about plot holes when I do my reviews of
stuff so yeah I'll wrap it up there so
yeah that's my take on plot holes
apropos of nothing whatever your
thoughts something but I've just talked
about drop something down on the
comments let's talk about it whole bunch
of stuff you can do such as like
subscribe there's buttons including a
link that will take you to my patreon if
you feel like supporting me in that way
if you don't though don't worry about it
other weeks you can check out don't want
to click on them that's fine too because
at the end of the day folks
you are the council I just from the
meetings and until next time this
council is a jerk
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]